hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey and Jason Dolan
Jason Dolan joining us today hey you're
the hot female guests for today it's
video Jason right um we have a top
reward tier video requests which Jason
don't lose heart I have reward
that's how you get here people yep this
is from a YouTube channel who has half
the subscribers we have Caleb City he's
doing okay
he's just doing alright on YouTube but
I've never actually seen his channel the
Gregory Bullock sent over this video
asking us to check it out Gregory
Bullock same name is me Bullock we have
the same last hang exciting and he said
you watch this it's called superhuman
interview I'm excited let's see what's
in store for us
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's right yogi shuttle spiders we
could definitely use that for like some
Intel or something man
well like thing is I have to do activate
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay people the time okay
[Laughter]
so Joanna Axl my power user what's your
power I could put people on a time loop
okay look you did this and then you put
yourself in a ton oh my god I do this
time turn it off turn it off
[Laughter]
does it time to erase your memory no
walking in here you know what
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Wow look over to all those accuracy got
how's amazing that was pretty amazing I
like how like in the time loop guys
wearing the same t-shirt but I've never
seen this guys videos before this looks
like so much fun to put together because
he obviously does these by himself
yeah and I always find that very
impressive like one of the my favorite
segments on YouTube is screwed rants
pitch beating and Ryan George does it
all by himself and watching like a whole
Skippy developed that way where you're
clearly hurt you gonna edit this
yourself but even with the way he edited
it when one character supposed to be
talking over the other it felt natural
in between the cuts yeah and there's
sort of a charm to having that home
video kind of quality to it there being
aware that this dude did it by himself
makes it that much more charming it's
gonna try to make it look insanely
professional makes it that much more
appealing actually it reminded me of
Andrew McCutchen from the you know the
Pittsburgh Pirates and Phillies now like
he has his Instagram account he does
like similar stuff to like this but I
love people that do this where they just
tape themselves and cut themselves back
and forth yeah it's hilarious one I mean
just the array of I have a soft spot in
my heart for superheroes with awful
powers yeah so you know like I wanted to
develop my own like take on Heroes where
it was just all the guys with the shitty
powers and so this really that's a
little bit of my heart well yeah like
this is a good time for me right now
because my childhood dreams are being
realized but I love the the spiders guys
just immediate out the bug I that was my
favorite guy the whole thing about the
cats fighting each other that's very
relatable fighting right now yeah I have
a whole situation we cast that are not
getting along so I did some really nasty
I was given a whole set of procedures
set of procedures like I you know don't
let these guys interact with each other
when you walk through that door yeah be
very careful what I thought this is well
done too because I thought that in the
editing he was able to make comedy out
of some of them not as high concept
moments you know certain things that are
just
mannerism or delivery base when the guy
just keeps stepping out the door he's
like why man yeah why man keep saying it
why that could have been a flat moment
but the way he cut it actually made it
pretty yeah I like this ideas too of
when he would go to like his self
vlogging POV shots result he was holding
the camera while he wanted all that
stuff added so much I keep using the
word charm but a charming I was just
charmed the whole time by this video
it's also it's like it didn't have great
audio but it's like it worked for this
you know like sometimes you watch these
things and it has the room tone in the
background or whatever add but for this
still if your [ __ ] is so funny that it
like survives things like that yeah
you're really onto something well it
could have felt I don't know if there
are worth pretentious but it could have
felt like it would be trying too hard
right he probably would have failed if
he was trying to make you look all-pro
by himself that's usually what happened
everything that's like on the right
level yes yeah because he's primarily
relying on his sense of humor for this
and his deliveries really sharp and I
think it can be kind of hard actually to
be fully aware when you're doing this by
yourself the right delivery when you
have characters interacting that they're
gonna overlap to have both of those
voices in your head while you're doing
one set of lines or else it might not
work it might not be funny but he
managed to make this whole thing
hilarious I won't check on more of this
guy's video I know Caleb city I want to
go
yeah man let's go girl the power consus
we're all really funny Gregory Bullock
thanks so much for recommending this
buddy
he's been one of our top patrons for a
long time as well all the way in
Massachusetts you stay vigilant and
watchful you beautiful bastard he keeps
singing with those velvety pipes JD
you're a screenwriter he is thinking of
actively pursuing being a writer I don't
know if he means my novelist or
scripting I think he wants to do scripts
as well but what would you tell a young
lad because what are you 60 69 69 hours
old how many years have you been 69
ever since I was 29 what would you tell
Gregory Bullock what he's pursued I
would say by final draft the software
because that makes it easy figure out
what your 10 favorite movies are by
those screenplays read those screenplays
watch the movie get saved the cat use
the formula break down the movies you
love and that's the number one place to
start
and then just start writing and the
first draft will be awful but then
you'll go back and you'll rewrite it
that'll be awful
then you'll rewrite it again a third
time that'll still suck put it in a
drawer forget about it come back to it
then you'll have good ideas do a rewrite
that'll be bad but you keep going
perseverance that is how you become a
writer
don't stop writing this sucks every lick
so I would love to be one of your
students master class I can see the
future a lot of suffering you want to be
a writer get used to some of that get a
hammer put your hand down
professor Dolan didn't give me a letter
grade he just wrote it sucks
he wrote put it in a drawer yeah alright
guys well you can subscribe to the
reject nation make sure to subscribe to
Caleb city if you haven't checked out
his channel already only has 500
subscribers come on guys struggling hit
the like button if you like this video
and Jason I haven't promoted you at all
forgive people faulty yeah oh wow I'm
Jay Dolan 74 Instagram Twitter that's
pretty much it and the vanishing of
Sydney Hall you can watch on Amazon
Prime's write all these things the
finishing of City Hall so you guys